قبل اكثر من 150 عاما حكم الرئيس الامريكي
اندرو جونسون امام مجلس الشيوخ فشل المجلس
في ادانته بعد جونسون ب 130 عاما اتهم
بلكلينتون بالحنث باليمين وعرقله سير
العداله وقتها رفعت عليه دعوه تحرش جنسي
لكن مجلس الشيوخ فشل في ادانت كلنتا
لم تكن سنوات حكم ترامب اكثر استقرار تعرض
للمحاكمه البرلمانيه مرتين خلال فتره
رئاسته الاولى بتهمه اساءه استخدام السلطه
وعرقله عمل الكونجرس والثانيه بتهمه
التحريض على العصيان خلال اقتحام الكونغرس
فشل مجلس الشيوخ في جمع الاصوات اللازمه
لادانته بكلته تهمتين لكن كل تلك
المحاكمات كانت امام مجلس الشيوخ فقط
اثناء وجود الرئيس في البيت الابيض عاده
تتبع وزاره العدل الامريكيه تقليدا قديما
بعدم توجيه الاتهام الى رئيس سابق يستند
هذا التقليد على الاعتقاد بان الرئيس
الحالي لا ينبغي ان يصرف انتباهه عن
واجباته الراهنه بسبب محاكمه رئيس سابق
وما يتبع ذلك من ضغوط اعلاميه وحزبيه
واجه العديد من رؤساء الولايات المتحده
تحديات وتحقيقات قانونيه بعد تركهم
مناصبهم لكن لم تتم مقاضاه او ادانه اي
منهم جنائيا هذه المره الاولى في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده يحاكم رئيس سابق امام
محكمه جنائيه شانهم في ذلك شان اي مواطن
امريكي لكنه كان رئيسا عليه فلا حصانه
لرئيس الامريكي سابق من الملاحقه القضائيه
بعد ترك منصبه يخضع لنفس القوانين
والاجراءات التي يقطع لها اي مواطن اخر
لانه كذلك الان يحضر الى محكمه منهات في
ولايه نيويورك لان القضيه مرفوعه هنا لكن
ماذا لو ادينا ترامب في نيويورك الاجراءات
القضائيه بعد الادانه معتمده على تفاصيل
القضيه ونتائج المحاكمه بشكل عام اذا
ادينا المدعى عليه في قضيه الجنائيه في
نيويورك فله الحق في الاستئناف خلال 30
يوما من تاريخ اصدار الحكم اذا تمت ادانه
ترامب في نهايه المطاف فيمكن استبعاده من
تولي انواع معينه من المناصب العامه في
ولايه نيويورك لن يكون لهذا بالضروره اي
تاثير على قدرته على الترشح للمناصب
العامه خارج الولايه بما في ذلك رئاسه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه